learning's I wonder if you would be good  enough to help me give out the next up  now this is a special honorary Oscar  that is being given to a man was found a  very comfortable home in the heart soon  all moviegoers needed people throughout  the world for the last 50 years years  ago when talking pictures first started  he had no peer whatsoever in the field  of romantic musical comedy and even  today he looks back over his shoulder he  can't seem to find a competitor  oh isn't the type to look back it is  because he looks forward because he  continues to make greater warmer and  more generous contributions to the  Academy and to the entire motion picture  industry with the Board of Governors has  voted to give this special honorary  award to one Maurice Chevalier  miss Russell I don't know how to thank  you  in fact I know how to thank you because  in my country we have a special way of  thanking an attractive lady we say can I  kiss you  auntie mommy